it's from the guardian EU raises
Prospect of big final ban if Twitter
fails to follow new legislation because
they don't have free speech in Europe
but what I want to point out is Yo our
our metrics are going really weird like
on YouTube it's like spiking and
dropping like weird stuff's going on and
I want to point out that I was supposed
to have a phone call with Google and
they canceled it had a call with them
yesterday so uh you know I don't trust
these these big tech companies behind
the scenes but uh that being said I
think Elon is doing a tremendous service
to humanity whatever his agenda may be
but of course in Europe they don't have
free speech so what's happened now there
was this uh they posted a video I think
Elon was talking to these EU guys they
say Elon Musk was told he had huge work
ahead to comply with eu's Digital
Services act which requires Tech firms
to tackle problems including abusive
posts and disinformation the eu's
commissioner for the internal Market
Terry Bretton told the Tesla CEO that
Twitter will have to significantly
increase efforts to pass the grade
implying the platform was in danger of
non-compliance with the ACT I welcome
Elon musk's statement of intent to get
Twitter 2.0 ready for the DSA said
Breton I am pleased to hear that he has
read it carefully and considers it as a
sensible approach to implement on a
worldwide basis but let's also be clear
that there is still huge work ahead as
Twitter will have to implement
transparent user policies significantly
reinforce content moderation and protect
freedom of speech and with that I got a
question what can they do to stop him
how do you ban Twitter find him find him
how
um
this is this is the point I was making
uh I was talking I told the story about
my friends when I was a kid I'm a bad
influence when I was like hey you want
to go skate I can't I'm grounded I'm
like okay well what does that mean it
means I can't go outside
okay what happens if you go outside I'll
get grounded more and what does that
mean it means I can't go outside longer
but you went outside already yeah I know
but I'll get in trouble bro you can go
outside I like very bad influence my
point is if Elon Musk is using starlink
for for communications if he makes his
own phone maybe he said he might if he
has to You Can't Ban apps in countries
in China and Iran they have Twitter even
though it's banned they'll find a way I
was gonna say he's gonna make them be
the bad guy he's going to be making them
be the new China EU is going to be
looked at as like a like a China type
and I've pointed this out on Twitter in
the past couple days everyone is
freaking out Apple was freaking out and
these countries are freaking out now
about free speech and stuff
um so why are they not freaking out a
couple years ago when they uh Apple was
I mean uh Twitter was being sued for two
different cases and there's I'm sure
there's more of child exploitation
content on the platform those individual
users were complaining to Twitter saying
this is me in the in the videos I am
underage please take this down Twitter
refused to take that content down we
were talking about this a few days ago
exactly what you just mentioned and
where is the EU to go to Twitter a year
ago and be like hey hey these things are
in violation of our laws but now they're
mad this is the statement that the EU
released today that they're mad that
he's going to be arbitrarily reinstating
banned users and that he's not pursuing
disinformation aggressively enough and
that they want a full quote extensive
audit of the platform so they are they
are mad that people are going to have
the ability to have free speech they are
mad that users are going to be brought
back and that they're lies of the state
are going to be officially challenged
this is all about power at the end of
the day the European Union knows the
government bureaucrats knows these
criminals in charge know that they could
only be in power if they could keep
conning and lying to everyone once you
have free speech that power goes away
once you have free speech that is all
threatened all of that could go away and
this is why we're seeing such very harsh
actions by the European Union that did
Levy very big fines against previous U.S
big tech companies like Facebook if you
remember it wasn't so long ago Facebook
had to pay off you know a lot of money
as well to the EU yeah so so so again
Google lost an appeal for for four
billion dollars in EU fines I was I was
taking a dump the other day and Facebook
wouldn't stop calling me true story I'm
not even kidding you know and it was
really annoying too because like I play
uh it's I posted it to I posted how
Google was calling me to talk about
section 230 and then a bunch of people
were like you this never happened and
I'm like I'll post this post a
screenshot of the email they sent me and
I got like the World Series of Poker I
love playing World Series of Poker and
uh and I'm trying to play this game and
then I get a call from Facebook and I'm
like what are you like close I don't
want to talk to you they called me three
times in like five minutes super creepy
and they were like we want to talk to
you about you know your marketing stuff
and what you're working on it was like
the most unhinged desperate thing that's
ever happened to me super weird they
they it was like a pitch to like buy ads
on Facebook because we have an account
and then they called me three times in a
row and then it was like that Trope of
the voicemail where it's like oh must
have just missed you uh I'm gonna give
you a call back and and maybe I'll get
you again I'm not getting I'm like what
are they doing it's super crazy like
you're not home uh well I'll just I'll
just try again yeah more and more
agitated they're seeing the writing on
the wall too because they're like if
this can happen to a company like
Twitter or whatever what's to stop it
from happening to a Creator and Company
like Facebook Mark Zuckerberg has lost
like over half of his net worth yeah his
company is cratering they're making cuts
and everything that that's why I'm
thinking they called me like crazy I'm
willing to bet that they've got you know
for their sales team it's like guys we
gotta ramp this up they light up what
like 11 000 people yeah there's the
stock price tanked I guess because of
meta or whatever the plan is that's the
other thing too they're they're
demonizing Elon Musk for making these
cuts and then ignoring Facebook is
making Cuts Amazon is making Cuts all of
these things they're like oh he took
over the platform and he's turning into
some crazy thing I'm like okay it's
happening all over the tech industry if
you're like paying attention right but
the thing is too about these um these
policies so they stopped enforcing the
covid-19 misinformation policy last week
um and then so my my thing is they're
more likely to be compliant with all of
these legal stuff if there are not
wasting their resources policing
opinions or policing coveted
misinformation do you know how much
Manpower that would take and they have
the whole report of how many suspended
accounts how many millions of posts that
were actioned of of covid posts or
whatever and I know AI helps a lot with
that type of stuff but still the
resources that are wasted on opinion and
political speech and silencing dissent
rather than actually going after like
child exploitation or actual legal
content on the platform do you know how
much like energy could be redirected
towards actual like crimes on the
platform like it's like mind-boggling
and you mean like illegal in the United
States
well I mean it would depend on the law I
believe for each country because I think
that's what Elon said and then I I know
I'm always confused by this I I see
always this like oh uh someone reported
this uh tweet it's not in violation of
German law or something yeah I see that
I always see that I'm like I don't even
know what that means no but it's a good
thing right so I've gotten these these
emails from Twitter where it's like
you've been reported in Pakistan or
something yeah and I I can't remember
who but someone a conservative said why
am I why is this being shown to me why
why is Twitter concerned about this and
I'm like no that's a good because then
if you go there you could be arrested
and I'm not I'm not kidding so Twitter
warning you that you've posted something
that they consider illegal is like hey
now you can't go there anymore it's a
good thing they notified you the German
law thing is because German Germany has
a law that they have to inform people so
even if you're outside the country they
have to inform you so the EU is all
sorts of insane
there was this um this video of this
woman she was a
uh from the Philippines I think she was
a journalist I don't know if you saw it
where she's talking with Colbert or
something like that and she's like
they're using free speech to stifle free
speech like it's just the craziest thing
but you can really see what their real
agenda is they want to be the
controllers of all information and have
no one else be able to speak out out of
turn of the narrative but the narrative
machine is crumbling and this is why
they were crying when Elon was taken
over those those already the messages we
saw what was it Vijaya uh she was like
she was like Hey we're going to work
with the government or something like
that we're going to work with you and
get this stuff sorted she's tied up in
that whole lawsuit uh that they're about
like collusion with the Biden uh
Administration
um so that's that's all going to come
out too I think but it seems like she
has her hands in a lot of things because
she's also with the hunter Biden laptop
and she was also the person who banned
Trump so evil people man it's crazy I I
hate to say it but man there's no
accountability you take a look I mean I
I think everybody listening knows you
take a look at what happened with Trump
and the fake impeachment stuff you take
a look at what Joe Biden did they
impeached Trump for what Joe Biden did
it's the craziest thing you take a look
at what the people at Twitter were doing
and you're like just where is a single
moment of accountability
Lane Maxwell okay fine they locked her
up but she was trafficking to no one no
accountability Sam bankman freed guy
just oh man he swindled four billion
dollars out of his investors or some
some amount of billions of dollars and
now he but he's still he's sorry he's
speaking at the New York Times right now
you can see really at the New York Times
right now in New York I think he's doing
a it's like a video call yeah if he
steps into U.S soil I imagine that he's
not going to leave I doubt it he made it
he made enough donations to Democrats to
live the rest of his life in comfort and
that's a lot of protection money yeah
dude so he was the CEO of FTX which was
like this this internet
um what would you call it like an
exchange for crypto and then they were
taking people's money and giving them
like a loan and they're holding their
their money as collateral and then he
was like investing their money in like
political campaigns I mean it's the most
hideous misuse of of people's investment
funds like Bernie Madoff stuff yeah I
don't know if you saw there's the guy
that asked him where'd all my two
million dollars in savings go and he's
like oh well I'm sorry about that didn't
yeah
no he's so disconnected from reality he
was having sex with like nine women in
his uh drug Shields just like all the
elites that's all they do and they were
taking all these different he would
entice his employees to take different
kinds of drugs to see which one they
like the best and help them work the
best his girlfriend's running Alameda
research which is his sister Corporation
that's taking it's like fight funneling
FTX funds and then investing it
um undercover yeah uh what's her name
Caroline uh you guys got her last name
Caroline I don't know man it's important
that these people stay in the media I
think she's a weird looking Jeep yeah I
was gonna say she's the weird looking
woman
it is it is crazy Caroline Ellison is
what people do with power it's a crazy
thing yeah like this this guy for
whatever reason comes into access and
he's like drugs and orgies
like I'm not surprised you know what I
mean like like it reminds me of that
experiment where they gave the rat the
electrode on its brain to trigger
dopamine it's like you give it's almost
like there's aliens and they're like
let's give this random guy a bunch of
money see what he does and he's just
pressing the button on his brain like
this feels good and the corporate media
is like look how humble he is look how
amazing look how nice and down to earth
he is what show was it where like you
look bad it's like an old clip and he's
like physically shaking yeah and I'm
like did nobody questions
ton of drugs absolutely drugs he is
shaking in that interview yeah it's like
at the time nobody nobody noticed that
like he's a literal tweaker yeah my
goodness and then you try you trust this
man because uh Jim Cramer called him the
next JP Morgan and Chase that I mean oh
that was crazy come on guys I like the
account unusual whales they um they
screenshot all of Jim Cramer's takes and
then they just like age so poor he's
blocked them by now but they age so
poorly that it's just so funny well
what's that other Twitter account like
reverse Kramer or something like that
yeah it's like whatever she says do the
opposite and then whenever someone does
something that he said to do they're
like oh they didn't reverse Kramer and
now they lost all their money I look at
Sam's name it's bank man fried like okay
is that an electric chair joke like what
is this simulation that we're in his
name is bank man well his family is all
connected to the Democratic party and
super Pacs that have been funneling a
crap ton of big money into the
Democratic uh establishment yo I'm all
about compassion and forgiveness but at
some point when someone swindles people
out of 4 billion or whatever how many
billions and millions and thousands of
dollars all these people lost to this
one drug addict you know horny 28 year
old nerd thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time